well as some industries are able to work
from home during the pandemic
first responders are still out there
interacting with people who may have
covet 19.
8 news now reporter kate houston shows
us that although they are taking
precautions
some are testing positive for the virus
samuel sheller and his ambulance company
guardian elite medical services
are adjusting how they respond to
emergency calls
they're now using these isolation hoods
while transporting patients
it allows them to cough and expel those
respiratory droplets without getting on
our providers
even with additional safety steps a
handful of his staff tested positive for
covid 19
some going to the icu we've had some
that have ended up on quarantine
after transporting patients that have
covet 19 so we've had to plan for those
staff members that are not available
along with maintaining our operational
ready law enforcement agencies are also
getting hit
overall 182 metro staff members have
tested positive for kovid 19.
deputy chief kelly mcmahon says 131 of
them are back at work
eric lloyd's death has really just
shocked us all and
it hit his heart every last one of us
because all of our officers
and employees across the line officers
and civilians
have had extremely minor symptoms at any
given time there may be 150 to 200 metro
employees that are not at work
due to coming in contact with the virus
or as they wait on test results
mcmahon says this is not affecting them
too much
as we have officers go out we have
others that are coming back from
quarantine
or coming back from from being sick so
we're ok
on the operation side the department is
doing extensive contact tracing to stop
any further spread of the virus mcmahon
says they're even watching
body camera footage to assist in that
effort kate houston
8 news now and since the start of the
global outbreak 20 las vegas fire and
rescue employees have tested positive
for cobit 19.
the city of las vegas says firefighters
and paramedics are wearing
full ppe when responding to those calls
brian